Thank you, Susan, for those generous words,
and thank you graduates, alumni and friends
for that generous welcome.
Heartfelt congratulations to you, our graduates,
and to your families for the hard work and
many accomplishments that have brought you
to this day.
I am especially grateful to John Lewis for
sharing his inspiring words and presence with
us.
There can be no finer example of how to live
a life than that of John Lewis, whose courage,
dedication, selflessness, and moral clarity
have for more than a half century challenged
this country to realize its promise of liberty
and justice for all.
It is an inexpressible honor and privilege
to stand on this stage beside him.
Almost eleven years ago I stood on this platform
to deliver my inaugural address as Harvard’s
28th president.
Today’s remarks represent something of a
bookend—a kind of valedictory—vale-dictory,
literally, farewell words.
When I spoke in 2007, I observed that inaugural
speeches are “by definition pronouncements
by individuals who don’t yet know what they
are talking about.”
By now I can no longer invoke that excuse.
I am close to knowing all I ever will about
being Harvard’s president.
I then went on to say something else about
the peculiar genre of inaugural addresses:
that we might dub them, as I put it then,
“expressions of hope unchastened by the
rod of experience.”
By now I should know that rod.
In my mind I hear the Jimi Hendrix of my youth
asking: “Are you experienced?”
I would have to answer affirmatively.
Perhaps not as experienced as Charles William
Eliot who made it through 40 years as Harvard
president.
But 11 years is a long time.
Think about it: the iPhone and I were launched
within 48 hours of each other in the summer
of 2007.
We are now so attached to our devices that
it seems almost unimaginable that they were
not always there.
The smartphone initiated a revolution in how
we communicate, how we interact, how we organize
our lives.
We are only beginning to understand the impact
of this digital transformation on our disrupted
society, economy, politics—and even our
brains.
2008 brought the financial crisis and the
loss of close to a third of our endowment—prompting
us in the ensuing years to overturn a system
of governance that had been in place since
1650, and to transform our financial—and
ultimately our investment—processes and
policies.
Five years ago, we lived through the marathon
bombings and the arrival of terror in our
very midst—and came together as Boston Strong.
We have experienced wild weather from hurricanes
to snowmageddon to bombogenesis, and doubled
down on our commitment to combat climate change.
We have confronted a cheating crisis, an email
crisis, a primate crisis, and sexual assault
and sexual harassment crises—and made significant
and lasting changes in response to each.
We have faced down H1N1, Ebola, Zika, and
even the mumps.
We have been challenged—as well as often
inspired and enlightened—by renewed and
passionate student activism: Occupy; Black
Lives Matter; Divest Harvard; I, Too, Am Harvard;
Undocumented at Harvard and hashtag Me Too.
We have faced a political and policy environment
increasingly hostile to expertise and skeptical
about higher education: the unprecedented
endowment tax passed last December will, we
estimate, impose on us a levy next year equivalent
to $2,000 per student.
There has indeed been a good measure of chastening.
But today I want to focus not on that “rod
of experience,” but on what I then defined
as the essence of an inaugural message: the
expression of hope.
Now, as then, that is what fills both my mind
and my heart as I think about Harvard, its
present and its future.
These past eleven years have only strengthened
my faith in higher education and its possibilities.
Hope, I have learned, derives not just from
the innocence of inexperience, but from the
everyday realities, the day-to-day work of
leading and loving this university.
At a time of growing distrust of institutions
and constant attacks on colleges and universities,
I want to affirm my belief that they are beacons
of hope—I think our best hope—for the
future to which we aspire.
In their very essence universities are about
hope and about the future, and that is at
the heart of what we celebrate today.
Hope is the foundation of learning.
The 6,989 graduates we honor today arrived
here with aspirations about what education
could make possible, with dreams about how
their lives would be changed because of the
time they would spend here.
Dean Rakesh Khurana regularly speaks to students
in the College about the transformations—intellectual,
social, personal—they should seek from their
undergraduate experience, urging them to articulate
their hopes and define a path toward realizing
them.
And we do have such very high aspirations
for them: that they find lives of meaning
and purpose, that they discover a passion
that animates them, that they strive toward
veritas, that they use their education to
do good in the world.
Never has the world needed these graduates
more, and I think they understand that.
I had lunch with a dozen or so seniors a month
ago, and I asked them to characterize their
four years here.
They spoke of the ways they had changed and
grown, but, more pointedly, they spoke of
how the world seemed to have changed around
them.
They worried about the health and sustainability
of the earth; they worried about the health
of our democracy and of civil society.
And they described how their attitudes and
plans had altered because of these changed
circumstances.
They no longer took their world for granted;
the future of our society, our country, our
planet could not be guaranteed; it was up
to them.
Their careers and life goals had shifted to
embrace a much broader sense of responsibility
extending beyond themselves to encompass an
obligation to a common good they had come
to recognize might not survive without them.
I thought of these students as something akin
to alchemists—confronting dark realities
and forging a golden path that offered hope—to
themselves about their own lives, but to all
of us as we imagine what these extraordinary
graduates will do with and for the damaged
world we offer them as their inheritance.
It would be impossible to be surrounded by
these students as they move through their
time at Harvard without being filled with
hope about the future they will create.
To paraphrase the Ed School’s Campaign slogan,
they are here learning to change the world.
Building a more enlightened world is of course
the fundamental work of the faculty as well,
and at the core of Harvard’s identity as
a research university.
The fundamental question we ask as we consider
appointing a professor is “What has this
person done to alter and enhance our understanding
of the world?”
Perhaps they have revealed how the microbiome
works, or how international trade agreements
affect economic prosperity, or how undocumented
students confront educational challenges.
Perhaps they’ve unlocked ways to identify
the actual location of genes that cause schizophrenia,
or have discovered how to engineer an exo-suit
to enable a person to walk.
Harvard scholars explore history and literature
to help us understand tyranny; art to illuminate
the foundations of justice; law and technology
to address assaults on fundamental assumptions
about privacy.
With its eye cast on creating a different
future, all of this work is founded in hope—of
seeing something more clearly, of influencing
others to change their understanding and perhaps
even their actions.
We are by definition a community of idealists,
thinking beyond the present and the status
quo to imagine how and when things could be
different, could be otherwise.
The privilege of interacting with Harvard’s
remarkable students and faculty, and the dedicated
staff who support their work has uplifted
me every day for the past eleven years.
It would be next to impossible not to believe
in the future they are so intent to build.
But there is another way that Harvard fills
me with hope, and that is the way we as a
community—living and working together within
these walls—are endeavoring ourselves to
grapple with the challenging forces dividing
and threatening the world—forces like climate
change, or the divisiveness that poisons our
society and polity, the undermining of facts
and rational discourse, the chilling of free
speech.
We might in some ways see the work we have
undertaken together on sustainability as emblematic
of these wider efforts.
We have come to consider ourselves a living
laboratory.
Our research and engagement on environmental
issues of course stretches well beyond our
walls: our faculty, for example, have played
critical roles in forging international climate
agreements, have engineered innovative ways
to create and store renewable energy, have
influenced regulatory frameworks from Washington
to Beijing, have explored the searing impact
of climate change on health.
But at the same time we have endeavored to
make our own community a model for what might
be possible—what we might hope for as we
imagine the future.
We have reduced our greenhouse gas emissions
by 30%, our trash by 44%; we produce 1.5 megawatts
of solar energy—enough to fuel 300 homes.
We have programs experimenting with healthy
building materials, green cleaning, and food
waste, and we have constructed HouseZero,
an energy neutral structure that is essentially
an enormous computer generating data about
every aspect of its operation and design,
making information available to others as
they build for the future.
We seek to be a living experiment in other
ways as well.
We gather here in Cambridge, face to face
in a residential educational setting because
we regard this very community as an educational
machine.
I have often observed that Harvard is likely
the most diverse environment in which most
of our students have ever lived.
We endeavor to attract talented individuals
from the widest possible range of backgrounds,
experiences and interests, the broadest diversity
of geographic origins, socio-economic circumstances,
ethnicities, races, religions, gender identities,
sexual orientations, political perspectives.
And we ask students to learn from these differences,
to teach one another—and to teach us as
well—with the variety of who they are and
what they bring.
This isn’t easy.
It requires individuals to question long-held
assumptions, to open their minds and their
hearts to ideas and arguments that may seem
not just unfamiliar, but even disturbing and
disorienting.
And it is an experiment that becomes ever
more difficult in an increasingly polarized
social and political environment in which
expressions of hatred, bigotry, and divisiveness
seem not just permitted but encouraged.
But in spite of these challenges all around
us, we at Harvard strive to be enriched, not
divided by our differences.
To sustain this vision of an educational community,
we must be a living laboratory in another
sense as well.
We must be a place where facts matter, where
reasoned
and respectful discourse and debate serve
as arbiters of truth.
There has been much recent criticism of universities
for not being sufficiently open to differing
viewpoints.
Protecting and nourishing free speech is for
us a fundamental commitment, and one that
demands constant attention and vigilance,
especially in a time of sharp political and
social polarization.
The uncontrolled—and uncontrollable—cacophony
that defines a university means we will inevitably
sometimes fall short; we cannot always guarantee
that every member of this community listens
generously to every other.
But that must simply motivate us to redouble
our efforts.
Silencing ideas or basking in comfortable
intellectual orthodoxy independent of facts
and evidence blocks our access to new and
better ideas.
We must be dedicated to the belief that truth
cannot simply be asserted or claimed but must
be established with evidence and tested with
argument.
Truth serves as inspiration and aspiration
in all we do; it pulls us toward the future
and its possibilities for seeing more clearly,
understanding more fully, and improving ourselves
and the world.
Its pursuit is fueled by hope.
Hope joins with truth as the as the very essence
of a university.
And so I come back to hope—the hope implicit
in our efforts to model a different way for
humans to live and work together, the hope
in the ideas and discoveries that are the
currency we trade in, the hope in the bright
futures of those who graduate today.
Yet as I step down from my responsibilities
as Harvard president, I am keenly aware of
another of hope’s fundamental attributes.
It implies work still unfinished, aspirations
not yet matched by achievement, possibilities
yet to be seized and realized.
Hope is a challenge.
I think of the words the beloved late crew
coach Harry Parker once spoke to a rower—words
I quoted often during the campaign: “This
is what you can be.
Do you want to be that?”
These are the words and the message I would
like to leave with Harvard.
The work is unfinished.
The job remains still to be done in times
that make it perhaps more difficult than ever.
May we continue to challenge ourselves with
the hope of all we can be and with the unwavering
determination to be that.
May Harvard be as wise as it is smart
As restless as it is proud
As bold as it is thoughtful
As new as it is old
As good as it is great.